bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sous le soleil en Normandie au
Festival du Film Romantique de Cabourg
avec aujourd'hui à mes côtés pour une
rencontre et trois petits points la
comédienne Lina Coudry et le comédien
François civil c'est vrai que j'ai pas
dormi beaucoup hein je tournais de nuit
cette nuit à Lille je suis en train de
tourner le film de Gilles Lellouche qui
s'appelle l'amour ouf tu t'amuses je
m'amuse énormément voilà j'ai deux
heures de sommeil dans les pâtes mais
ravi quand même donc je vais beaucoup
parler voilà exactement j'ai posé des
questions comment ça va Alina Coudry
[Musique]
bah oui j'étais bien amusé je me suis
tellement éclaté j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec Lina pour la première
fois ensuite on sait pas quitter pendant
quelques projets mais c'est là qu'on
s'est rencontré Vincent Cassel Romain
Duris puis au Marmaï en fait c'est rare
je crois ce genre de projet dans le
cinéma cet envergure là le temps que ça
nous a pris pour le faire c'est une
grande chance quoi qu'on a eu on n'a pas
moi j'avais déjà on m'avait jamais déjà
j'avais jamais vu un film comme ça en
France plus on n'avait jamais proposé un
truc comme ça et d'en faire partie
forcément c'est après
surtout de voir que le public était au
rendez-vous et d'avoir les retours qu'on
a eu enfin franchement parce que c'est
un gros pari quand même en fait c'est
une conjoncture quand même de choses qui
font que j'ai envie de de participer à
un film mais le personnage c'est quand
même le la clé de voûte le ou la metteur
en scène les partenaires le scénario
lui-même mais il finit ce qui va me
raccrocher tout le temps du tournage de
la préparation et même de la promotion
c'est le c'est le personnage donc j'ai
besoin de d'être séduit par lui ou en
tout cas ou même d'être dérangé par lui
d'être mais en tout cas qui se passe
quelque chose entre les mois il faut
être je sais pas si c'est séduit tout
moi j'ai l'impression de soi qu'il faut
que je me reconnaisse au moins un
endroit il y a au moins une scène où je
me dis je comprends son instinct tu vois
ce que je veux dire et à partir de là je
vais réussir à créer un truc ici à il y
a des personnages que je trouve trop
beau et parfois j'arrive pas à connecter
et il y a des fois où je veux que ce
soit pour moi et ouais j'y arrive pas
quoi je trouve pas le je trouve pas la
porte donc je sais pas si c'est de la
séduction si j'ai besoin d'être séduite
par le truc ou pas j'arrive pas à c'est
trop c'est trop abstrait dans ma tête
une zone à défendre qui nous réunit à
Cabourg l'histoire de Greg que
j'interprète qui a un flic un filtré
dans une ZAD et il rencontre le
personnage de Lina qui s'appelle Myriam
qui ne jeunes addiste militante et en
fait ils vont vivre une histoire d'amour
évidemment contrarié parce que moi je
suis infiltré là dedans donc il est
question de séduction un peu dans le
film mais en fait elle est biaisée par
le mensonge de de mon personnage après
l'art de la séduction moi je pense que
je suis un chien piètre artiste du coup
si c'est un si c'est levé au radar moi
ça sera généralement très mal quand
j'essaye de séduire c'est quand même
très soit c'est assez maladroit
j'ai l'impression de vouloir séduire et
je l'envoie aucun signaux moi je sais
pas consciemment de séduire je pense que
j'essaye de séduire mais c'est pas non
mais tu vois je fais pas un effort en me
disant il faut que ah il y a telle
personne je veux là je veux la séduire
absolument je veux l'avoir dans mon
entourage où je veux des relations
amoureuse et amicale et si tu vois une
fille que trop belle et que tu as envie
de tu vas aller vers elle non je vais
être terrifié autant que si je croise
une réalisatrice ou réalisateur et qui
j'ai très envie de travailler je vais
pas y aller parce que ça me non mais j'y
vais pas non plus c'est un mec j'avoue
c'est vrai donc tu fais quoi quand il y
a quelqu'un qui te plaît
non c'est vrai que plus j'avance dans la
vie moins j'ai le sentiment de devoir
séduire
et toi
et moi attends je me pose vraiment la
question après c'est vrai
ou comme on dépend du désir des autres
pour travailler ou pas forcément il faut
entretenir un certain certaines formes
de séduction je me souviens que ah je
sais plus qui avait dit ça mais qui
disait qu'on était en ce métier c'était
une recherche constante de
reconnaissance et d'amour et d'amour
finalement donc et c'est pour ça que je
te dis je l'élargis en fait pas que je
fais ce métier je pense parce que c'est
plus profond chez nous les acteurs et
les actrices ce besoin d'amour mais
qu'en fait ça concerne tout le monde
c'est comme des pièges à chaque fois
parce que tu te retrouves dans des
relations
d'intérêt finalement et en même temps
moi j'ai pas du tout envie d'être là
dedans et de me dire que je rencontre
vraiment les gens et je peux pas faire
comme si c'était pas vrai que quand je
rencontre un réalisateur ou une
réalisatrice et que j'ai envie d'être
dans le film il y a pas de séduction il
y en a forcément un peu mais c'est vrai
que tu vois l'art de la séduction au
moins en fait plus on avance dans nos
carrières et on a la chance que ça se
passe bien tous les deux moi on passe de
casting et je trouve que dans le casting
au moins tu as la chance de pouvoir
séduire avec ton travail et quand on me
propose un rôle directement en fait
c'est presque plus flippant ce que tu
m'avais raconté avec Cédric sur backner
c'est très très drôle c'était quoi déjà
ou tu pensais passer un casting et lui
il t'a appelé pour le rôle et jusqu'au
bout tu croyais pas que tu avais raison
qui me le propose pas
ouais il m'en parle un peu je comprends
pas s'il me le propose on fait des on
fait des des essais avec d'autres gens
machin et après je suis sur le plateau
je joue le rôle on n'a jamais dit
c'était moi et tu te sens en Challenge
tout le temps tu sens que tu es encore
le alors
discussion comme ça
[Musique]